est-ce qu'on se croirait pas encore un
petit peu en été je sais pas vous mais
là on est au mois d'octobre
franchement un temps assez incroyable
donc j'en profite pour vous parler de
lunettes de soleil des lunettes de
soleil pas cuites sacrament des lunettes
de soleil pas comme les autres qui vous
permet de faire plein de choses et
notamment d'écouter de la musique sans
avoir absolument rien dans les oreilles
uniquement par vibrations de la musique
dans votre tête et ça croyez moi c'est
complètement hallucinant
[Musique]
donc je vous parle de bain de soleil
n'est pas n'importe quelle pièce mais
lui être que j'ai reçu l'autre jour ce
sont les algues where them girls
je pense qu'il vous connaissez viper
c'est des lunettes sont connectés les
qui font beaucoup plus que ça better
than you extrait si elles sont
meilleures vos anciens livres de soleil
en plus d'être des lunettes de soleil
franchement style et elles ont un autre
avantage
comment ça ne la laissez moi vous
montrez bien à l'intérieur alors ça
c'est le câble manuel d'utilisation qui
est là pour le recharger comment ça
marche ça tout ça super joli ce que je
vous propose c'est que j'apprenne
vraiment à les utiliser à comprendre
comment il marche et une fois que c'est
au top là dessus je vous fais un petit
débris et je vous explique comment
marcher lunettes ou vous pouvez les
trouver quoi comment et à quel prix
vous mettrez bien sûr les liens en bas
dans la description bon pour moi ça va
être quelques heures voire quelques
jours pour les prendre en main pour vous
ça va durer le temps d'un
elles sont hyper cool plusieurs raisons
déjà franchement elles sont plutôt pas
mal alors moi j'ai une petite tête donc
tout de suite qu'il elle de soleil un
petit peu voilà ça dépasse un peu mais
ça ça revienne ma tronche dans la petite
tête forcément c'est comme ça par contre
ce qui est vraiment bien avec ses
lunettes de soleil c'est que grâce à ça
cette petite partie qui vient se poser
ici là directement sur votre tête en
contact avec votre boîte crânienne
il ya une vraie conduction du sont
justement qui se fait et vous entendez
la musique dans notre tronche enfin
c'est pas un effet qui est très bizarre
c'est un effet que final assez naturel
et vous avez vraiment l'impression
d'écouter de la musique sauf que vous
avez les oreilles libre donc ça c'est
vraiment bien lorsque vous êtes en vélo
en ville par exemple vous écoutez votre
musique en même temps vous écouter
vraiment ce qui se passe autour de vous
ce qui fait que c'est hyper sécurisé
laissez moi vous expliquer comment ça
marche
le phénomène est vraiment tous qu'on est
assez sympa on prend un carton qui
vivent qui en gros va représenter votre
tête alors je ne dis pas que votre tête
est vide je ne dis pas ça du tout et je
dis que ça va nous servir de caisse de
résonance on va prendre nos lunettes de
soleil la première chose à faire c'est
d'allumer nos lunettes de soleil en et
puis ici sur les deux boutons
il expliquera après les différents
boutons on laisse appuyé elle s'allume
ensuite on synchronise directement en
bluetooth
gods and girls c'est la connected elles
sont connectées et là maintenant je peux
balancer de la musique directement mon
iphone là et je vais entendre donc là
vous avez le sont uniquement avec les
bulles est maintenant je mets ça dessus
des choses dessus je les écarte pas
dessus
akasaka en fait les faits assez bluffant
c'est très marrant parce que là vous
avez la musique on entend un petit peu
de sens on peut pas dire qu'on n'entend
pas moi j'entends par contre vraiment
bien là dans ma tronche mais ce qui est
vraiment se rendre compte vous dit vous
le posez là dessus ça fait caisse de
résonance
c'est surtout parce que si j'enlève on
entend tout de suite beaucoup moins bien
donc c'est vraiment ça qui se passe
lorsque vous mettez vos lunettes de
soleil zangl vous avez le sont dans la
tête le son est propre
j'ai l'impression de l'entendre sa tombe
j'ai l'impression de l'entendre vraiment
directement dans mes oreilles
alors qu'en fait j'ai les oreilles qui
sont complètement libre et disponible
pour entendre vraiment ce qui se passe
aux alentours
et ça franchement c'est hyper bien
sécurisé c'est pratique c'est novateur
et c'est super cool mais au delà de 100
va beaucoup plus loin parce qu on a
différents boutons vous expliquer à quoi
ils servent
vous allez sur le côté sur le côté
gauche de boutons sur les boutons de
volume
vous allez pouvoir monter et baisser
elles sont tout simplement comme ça au
moins vous allez vraiment régler le
niveau de votre musique quand vous êtes
dans la rue vous choisissez vous le
paramétrer comme vous voulez c'est
plutôt pas mal et des boutons pour
naviguer pour avancer pour reculer la up
j'avance je change de vidéos j'aurais pu
une fois je vais encore changer de
vidéos derrière je peux m'appuyer ça me
change de vidéos je remet la vidéo
d'avant je remet encore la vidéo d'avant
je remet encore la vidéo d'abord et là
je fini par retomber sur la mène donc ça
c'est cool donc là je vous le montre
avec une application youtube mais vous
pouvez faire avec tout ce que vous
voulez vous le faire avec spotify vous
pouvez faire avec votre compte apple
musique bien évidemment youtube et
toutes les applis qui vont vous envoyer
du son vous pouvez paramétrer d'un côté
je monte je baisse le volume de l'autre
côté
j'avance de chansons j'avance de ty
j'avance de vidéos gérant de tout ce que
je veux je reviens en arrière et c'est
cool mais ça ne s'arrête pas là on a
aussi notre fonctionnalité de
intelligence artificielle et ça croyez
moi c'est vraiment bien parce qu'en fait
on va retrouver syrie où google
assistant directement avec vos lunettes
vous avez un bouton dédié vous appuyez
dessus le téléphone fait dans le sac
dans la poche où vous voulez vous avez
une portée de 10 mètres donc le
téléphone peut être posée même à
distance vous appuyez et vous avez syrie
à la commande vocale appelée maman
appelé ma femme appelée si syrie joue
moi tel morceau série mais moi si ce qui
fait que vous avez un vrai mains libres
une vraie dispo alors mains libres oui
et non parce que vous devez quand même
appuyé pour commander syrie mais par
contre c'est vraiment cool ça marche
très très bien
le bouton situe sur la branche gauche il
suffit d'appuyer et hop ça va activer
syrie et ça il faut le reconnaître quand
même c'est plutôt cool hautes fonctions
qui écoule accès lunettes
on peut passer un coup de fil sa vache
en train d'appeler avec mes lunettes tu
m'entends bien
ouais le son est cruel ouais c'est
rigolo
ouais ouais ça va qu'est ce qu'il fait
tu veux pas le dire c'est ça c'est
intime tu fais cuire la mousse avec ses
magnifiques baba tout à l'heure bisous
alors vous voyez ça marche extrêmement
bien pour passer des coachings voilà
donc ça c'est cool c'est aussi une des
fonctionnalités qui est vachement sympa
de ses lunettes en gueule c'est que vous
avez effectivement plusieurs cas
d'application vous pouvez passer des
coups de fil vous avez l'intelligence
artificielle google assistant siri
pouvez donc faire tout ce que vous
voulez avec piloter votre maison avoir
une commande vocale pour vous guider
pour aller par exemple d'un point a à un
point b grâce au gps vous avez bien
évidemment la musique là il ya pas mal
de choses c'est cool
j'ai maintenant vous montrer un petit
peu les différents points techniques de
ces lettres et vous allez voir
franchement elles sont super cool je
vous le disais donc les différents
boutons vous allez monter ici et baisser
le volume
vous allez aussi pouvoir changer de
morceau en revenir en arrière naviguer
le bouton là c'est pour venir allumé et
arrêtez votre musique tout simplement
vous appuyez cela us à la baisse et le
bouton ici vous servirez active et
l'intelligence artificielle syrie ou de
l'assistant tout simplement pour les
allumer pour les éteindre et vous suffit
d'appuyer en même temps sur les deux
boutons la power of elles s'éteignent et
pour les rallumer j'ai fait ici en même
temps sur les deux boutons
quand elles clignotent elle recherche la
synchro et quand elles sont
synchronisées hop ça s'éteint
pour les recharger c'est aussi hyper
simple vous avez un cordon ici vous
allez branché en usb et de l'autre côté
vous allez branché chaque partie ça
vient comme ça se positionner à
l'intérieur sur les deux branches et ça
se recharge en une heure vous avez fait
une charge complète ses lunettes elle se
connecte directement à votre smartphone
à votre n'importe quel appareil que ce
soit un ordinateur ou une tablette grâce
au bluetooth 5.0 vous avez une batterie
à l'intérieur de 115 millions père
heures qui vous donne à peu près quatre
heures d'écouté de musique et sans
heurts en étant lui mais elles ont une
certification ipx4 qui vont les protéger
contre les éclaboussures alors l'idée là
dessus c'est effectivement de ne pas les
mettre dans la flotte ou les jetez pas
dedans de toute façon lorsqu'il pleut il
n'y a pas trop d'intérêt d'avoir des
lunettes de soleil
lorsque vous êtes sous la tempête
tropicale donc en règle générale vous
avez pas les maîtres mais si vous faites
du vtt qui et les éclaboussures vous
allez être protégés et ça aussi c'est un
point assez intéressant et comme on
parle lunettes de soleil vous avez des
verres polarisés uv400 qui vous protège
vraiment contre les rayons de soleil ça
c'est plutôt cool
et en plus de ça sont des verts qui sont
complètement interchangeables vous
pouvez aller sur le site de zangl vous
avez différents d'arts vous pouvez
choisir et aussi différentes couleurs
je trouve que google a bien réussi sa
copie et a fait des lunettes qui sont
vraiment très jolie ce silent ce qu'ils
me voulaient les petits détails qui sont
très sympas également sur le vers la
world beats ce sont des lunettes qui
sont faites pour vous protéger du soleil
pour permettre d'écouter de la musique
sans être en danger en ayant tout le
temps les oreilles libre et ça vraiment
je peux le dire c'est quelque chose qui
est vraiment très sympa en termes de
qualité sonore on n'aura pas exactement
la même qualité que si vous aviez des
écouteurs avec un son complètement ouf
par contre c'est assez bluffant
ça marche très bien vous l'avez vu
lorsqu'on fait le test de conduction
avec le carton c'est quelque chose qui
fonctionne extrêmement bien c'est plutôt
cool
d'autant plus que google c'est une
entreprise américaine qui est basée à
los angeles
je trouve que le produit est bien finie
c'est la deuxième version il ya une
toute première version 6 cellules est
vous intéresse je vous ai mis un lien
en bas dans la description pour aller y
jeter un oeil et pourquoi pas les
prendre
toutefois elle vous botte vous pouvez
aussi l'utiliser pour les vacances de
sports d'hiver pas forcément que pour
l'été puis pourquoi pas si vous allez à
saint bar cet hiver why not
on peut se faire plaisir on ces jeunes
et voilà je vous invite bien évidemment
mais c'est tous vos commentaires la
tuque dites-moi si une technologie comme
celle là avec de la musique par
conduction osseuse peut vous intéresser
est-ce que vous avez déjà testé des
lunettes de ce type vous avez bien
évidemment à marquer tout ça comme ça on
reste ensemble on reste connectés en
pareille puisse rester connecté parce
que y avoir plein de nouveautés plein de
choses super intéressantes des tests des
exclus plein de trucs de ouf
donc on reste ensemble soyez sages à
très bientôt je vous embrasse ciao tour
[Musique]
on